this is the all-new Nike Vapor matte 190
dollar running shoe that took seven
years to make the upper is pretty
standard Nike but the soul is well it's
different there's no foam there's no
rubber just a system of air-blast these
sneakers may well be the future the
company but are they any good we took
them for a spin to find out so these
things look like spaceships but
otherwise the Nassau back there is kind
of low honestly on a run the shoe
doesn't feel drastically unique not like
bouncing on a trampoline or running on a
waterbed mattress and it's the subtle
things that kind of stand out they're
really light and they're more flexible
than they look there's also a good bit
of pop but it doesn't feel synthetic and
the bounce is mostly in the heel someone
who tends to run striking with the
middle or the front of their foot won't
even notice that much maybe the most
impressive thing is that need little
jellyfish bladders didn't pop like water
balloons when they came down hard on a
curb or subway great another selling
points durability the air bladders are
filled with nitrogen which unlike foam
cushioning won't break down well the
shoes can theoretically go a lot farther
than 500 miles it's kind of the standard
recommended life for running [ __ ]
finally the sole is modular look for
Nike to start monkeying with these
different air pods to make models that
are more minimal more cushion more firm
etc
in truth how the vapor Mac sneakers
perform on a run isn't as important as
one might think
3/4 of athletic shoes never see a track
or a field they're bought for the street
the style if you will they're bought
more often than not for walking these
sneakers do that just fine
[Music]